for a while I couldn't wear khakis
they were so blockbuster specific the
blue shirt and the the khakis God I'm
fascinated is this going well hi my name
is John Cho and these are my essentials
okay
glasses this year I need reading glasses
I was walking by a Warby Parker and got
these ordered inside of 15 minutes and
I'm glad I got the real deal then you
need sunglasses and these are Garrett
light it's sunny in LA so they're
necessity on the other hand I was just
thinking recently like is this a scam
that we all bought into when I was a kid
I never had sunglasses and I was outside
all day but now I feel like I need them
my face feels naked without them and if
you start getting used to your face with
them then it becomes suddenly
preposterous to go outside without them
I try my best to take care of them but
they're like children I've abused at
some point they leave you in anger all
right books
this is all stuff I brought on the
airplane so I read this on the way here
even if you're a movie person at minimum
takeoff and landing you need something
to read this is a parker posey the
memoir that I just read called you're on
an airplane which I read on the plane
and I happen to be in it and you see
what Parker did she sent me a copy with
my name highlighted because she knows
I'm in egomania yeah I don't always
finish books and that's okay it's not
homework I don't finish a lot of movies
either if I'm half an hour in and I
don't care then I've given myself
permission to parachute out you start
with the glasses and now the books I'm
starting to feel like an old man get off
my lawn kids like most human beings on
planet Earth I need music and these are
my favorite they're so they're super
balanced this is really soft you're
going across an ocean any little thing
that bothers you will bother you a lot
after ten hours yeah these are corded
but I bring the Bluetooth pods and I
just find these are great for a walk or
workout not having the cords and also
taxi rides and subway rides I don't know
if I have large ear holes but I had to
put the black phone on them to make them
stick but other than that it's just
incredibly convenient particularly for
planes on getting into toothpicks these
mint tea tree toothpicks they're good
for loitering on street corners as well
and bullying children because it makes
you look tough my mouth feels like ass
about 45 minutes in to any flight I
wonder if there's like some weed
primates when we don't feel great to
chew on bark to feel more grounded yeah
I like to derive pleasure through my
mouth another essential is a
and kids you can't write everything on
your phone this is a fountain-pen
of which I found pretty recently in
Winnipeg writing is very pleasurable on
this now when you go to like a cheap pen
it feels like you're writing on sand
paper that it feels like there's a lot
more friction than there is and this is
so smooth on a plane you're gonna get
asked to fill out those immigration
forms and they don't get pins out
anymore so you're gonna have to borrow
them from somebody unless you have the
smartypants like me there we go I think
I got this at Sundance and I actually
didn't know what it was it's a huge
battery and when traveling you can get
down on the phone juice real fast so
always pack this and make sure it's
powered up the night before
it's called hue you know I just wish
that this can connect to the laptop do
you know of it if they make those oh
they do we have a complicated
relationship I turned off Siri I was
recently told that Siri listens to you
and makes advertising suggestions I just
like that about her so I broke up with
her but you know there's games as the
social media there's there's the email
eighteen thousand three hundred
seventeen unread emails it's not good
you had my hair isn't always this
perfect I also got this from the city in
the country of Canada called Winnipeg
and middle province is supposed to be
Manitoba and I just thought it was a
poetic phrase I was strictly into reppin
Los Angeles for a while and I
particularly liked going to other cities
and reppin LA on my head people who are
transplanted here from New York or
Boston or Chicago and living in Los
Angeles for 35 years and still going Sox
go Sox I'm like give it up
you're an Angeleno you have to come to
grips with your own life situation
this is uh my hair stuff my barber is uh
is from Hawaii he just sent me home with
this it is a pace that's like super
strong and because our hair is so wiry
now it's sort of the only thing I use
super strong mmm it's dry goes in it's
gone this little heart says peace
[Music]
another essential I still use this old
laptop because it has a DVD driver and
even though I use it less and less I'm
still I'm hanging on they still send
screeners in in that form although it's
moving towards digital and giving you
codes and stuff it's still still
handy-dandy to have one of these as a
reminder essentials and this is all the
travel stuff because this is what I have
with me but I got this bag because I
used to be a backpack guy and I was
putting it underneath the seat in front
of me as they instruct you to do which
left not enough room for my feet so I
got this which has a pretty narrow
profile and it can go underneath your
thighs that area and it also stands up
you can just reach in it has a zipper on
top and instead of having to do this you
can even just reach in through the top
it's in the same compartment and this is
supposed to be a camera bag and it comes
to these modular dividers for your
lenses by peak design but I took those
out it's made travelling a lot easier
hot talk again thank you for watching I
hope your life has been nourished by
this information I hope you leave this
video loving me more